just keep hearing the [ __ ] numbers
the numbers the numbers Mason why do
they mean ah let me just explain what is
going on in case you've been living
under a rock basically I am the cause of
the ad pocalypse you may have heard of
it
you know PD pipes actually the cost of
the apocalypse' PT pipe single-handedly
ruined almost all that's right that was
me okay I take full responsibility be
it's written I take full responsibility
that was definitely me putting those ads
on those videos that was me that was all
me you're right assuming my singing the
ad pocalypse basically leading to a ton
of ads pulling out of YouTube and
effectively a ton of our videos
constantly getting demonetized
constantly the yellow symbol flying
across the board you probably heard a
ton of craters complain about this
already just want to make sure we're on
the same page now recently a lot of
youtubers struggling with another
monetization have noticed a striking
pattern when a video gets demonetized
it gets a fraction of the views does
anyone else experience this dukkha
dukkhata once it's yellow it is removed
from any form of recommendation or
trending
even I noticed this I noticed this to
make sense from a business perspective
in them in though its job as hell so
basically once the video hits yellow the
views goes hello I mean by they go by
that's what I've noticed a lot of people
did as well okay but then YouTube
YouTube reply and be like no that's not
the case basically saying that the
yellow icon alone doesn't impact search
and discovery but if the video is also
not suitable provider audience then you
might see a poor performance so they're
basically saying if it gets to monetize
it has nothing to do with no reviews
okay but if a video has explicit content
then it's sucking again as many views
but your video is to monetize because
you don't have explicit content yeah
they're saying yes and no at the same
time it's like tennis it's a going back
and forth hey yeah we a we touch around
the issue numbers what are they mean now
something recently a very interesting
came to light thanks to a study that
showed that according to their analysis
YouTube is systematically suppressing
content that have limited monetization
or have been completely demonetized
how did they notice this you asked
through the numbers the numbers what do
they mean just want to point out this is
a Swedish study so you know 100% how
legit it is now YouTube have a hidden
variable called excluded underscore ads
in the source code of all videos with
monetization enabled you can access this
variable by right-clicking and selecting
view page source
vanna simply press control f and search
for excluded underscore ads if your
video is d monetized it will have one of
the following key variables 102 104 or
let's go and check this out let's go to
my demonetized section which I also like
to call all my content okay okay all
right
excluded ads there we go
46 64 76 89 106 115 now after noticing
these numbers youtubers started to try
and figure out what are the numbers mean
what are they mean thanks to the channel
nerd City the numbers so far that has
been discovered
102 profanity and rough language 104
means sexually suggestive content 109
sensational and shocking 113 tragedy and
conflict 115 sensitive social issues I
don't know okay people are still trying
to figure it out and if your video got
demonetized do help out and share the
costs but what the study also discovered
was that videos that did get demonetised
significantly got less traction that the
videos that were monetized at least if
they have lower viewership so what our
research shows is what do you monetize
the videos especially with lower
viewership or less promoted than
monetized videos with the same
viewership to a very great extent such a
significant difference can only be
caused if YouTube is actively devaluing
the monetized videos using some sort of
function so videos will lower viewership
can't compete against monetize the
videos but as the views gets higher more
and more videos are able to push through
despite with the evaluation thereby
causing the visible pattern in the graph
which otherwise would not exist
so basically videos like mine should
technically push through even if they do
get demonetized but if you have a
smaller channel goodbye you need some
prior knowledge and if
you watched my last video on AI then you
will easily understand this video isn't
that great because YouTube the way
YouTube runs its recommendation system
and there D monetization system is run
through an AI a deep neural network
which we know with that it's it's a
self-taught AI which basically means
it's not YouTube going hey do this okay
huh it's a it's a it's a it's a yes
entity people didn't fear AI before just
think of how much I fear the YouTube
recommendation here there's base there
there's document about this published
sized and it's actually really
interesting
I love how advanced this is especially
if you go back because back in the day
with with the reason for an AI to even
exist to have recommendation videos is
because back in the day on YouTube
the only way you would find a video was
for searching the title or the tags now
people started to immediately abuse this
by writing the exact same title and the
exact same tags as the video remember
boob girls reply girls sorry that's
their name they would basically show up
in the recommended bar for popular
videos because they would copy their
title and their tanks so people started
abusing the system and it just didn't
work anymore and YouTube had to come up
with something better so it's really
funny to me how this is they had this
advanced study on neural networks it's
thanks to poop girls Thank You boob
girls now it's really interesting
because a neural network needs a goal
and incentive they work just like human
beings if you know because you watch my
video for example the Mario self-taught
AI which was an AI that taught itself
how to play Mario it's it's incentive
which was named in this case Fitness was
increased by walking in the right axis
you see the Fitness increases that's his
goal and then through trial and error
Mario improves and can play the game
better YouTube recommendation works in
the exact same way or in at least a very
similar where it's incentive is based on
watch time the the AI takes videos that
they think will increase the watch time
tested on a few people did it increase
watch time and if the answer is yes
throw would you know throw a here's the
video to everyone because it increases
watch time on YouTube
this one was demonetised most likely a
go away ok and it's a really interesting
solution to this problem because if you
solely based video recommendation on
likes then controversial videos wouldn't
make it to recommend it but at least now
we can better understand why demonetized
videos doesn't get recommended or why
they don't get as many views because
recommended is a huge part of our
viewership because since YouTube has
really thrown out the whole subscription
idea more and more out the window
because their goal is to increase watch
time that's what gonna give them better
ads and it makes sense I will say Tom
Scott did a video about this where he
explains how the YouTube algorithm works
he explains his thousand times better
than I do but I did find it really
interesting how he pointed out that the
flaw in this AI which is that even
though its goal is to increase watch
time it can't determine what the quality
of the video is it doesn't know exactly
what what the video is about what what
is it contain and that's what it's been
trying to do now with the demo
monetization in picture with where the
AI will scan the video it will scan the
thumbnail we know there's technology to
do this we can use an example here
there's my thumbnail it's a person it's
okay it's against the title is it scans
the description the tags and the caption
to determine if the video is monetizable
or not because there's no way YouTube
would be able to do this on all its
content because and it is so much is
uploaded on YouTube every single day it
needs an AI to fully function but I
found it really interesting how he
points out the flaw in AI it can't tell
the difference between videos that are
suitable for children made with
education in mind and creepy trademark
infringing on a fish
efforts it just knows what kids click on
and what they watch so the YouTube
algorithm promotes stuff that gets more
watch time but it doesn't really know
what it is it can do its best effort too
and you can tell this is something that
YouTube had to do last minute because it
recently came out what people call ad
pocalypse - and I'm not responsible for
this one thank you
ads are pulling out now because it was
discovered that really creepy and
disturbing videos were shown and
promoted to millions of kids because it
was picked up by the algorithm and
promoted to them
Tom predicted it it's kind of
interesting there was also a search
result basically when you type in how to
it showed up how to have sex with your
kids it showed how to have sex with your
kids it's weird wasn't this video
educational don't we all understand each
other a little better but the numbers
what do they mean only you can tell us
what the codes mean I find it really
interesting because this is what happens
constantly where you two can't say what
they're doing because if they explain
what they're doing
people are gonna abuse the algorithm but
it also leads to the effect of people
discovering numbers and trying to figure
out what they mean and we have every
right to try and to like this is our job
this is our livelihood we depend on this
having the videos we monetize is a huge
deal and especially as we've seen now
for smaller channels obviously we as
creator need to work together to figure
out all these things but at the same
time YouTube they need to hide the
information from us but inevitably leads
to chaos every single time who wins here
no one that seems to be a common census
in all my videos now is a great time if
you want to support your creators buy
their merch support their patron
especially if they are smaller hopefully
the AI will improve that's what they're
saying and that's how self taught neural
networks work this has been PewDiePie
leave a like and hopefully we can get
this to trending if you share like and
watch the whole thing twice watch it
again
again and again see this is what you
really should be telling at the end of
the video hey watch the video again
[ __ ] you going somewhere
open a new tab and click again come
alright squad fair man